chez nova pl est l'activité a repris
après une période de chômage partiel les
salariés sont à leur poste mais avec
l'épidémie cette pme familiale
spécialisée dans la transformation de
matières plastiques a dû réorienter sa
production
ce que nous faisons habituellement
aujourd'hui est en sommeil
nous avons des commandes en suspens que
l'entente of legends rouvre et nous
avons mobilisé l'essentiel de nos
énergies principalement vers cette
protection contre la prolifération du
virus
désormais l'entreprise fabrique des
visières de protection adaptative mais
également des séparateurs en plexiglas
qui intéresse beaucoup les pharmaciens
buralistes coiffeur dentiste ou même
restaurateurs donc il s'agit de
protection de comptoir essentiellement
qui sont des plaques d'épaisseur 3,4 mm
qui sont pris dans un système de
piétements qui peuvent se mettre soi
horizontalement soit verticalement avec
la possibilité que des vies des ultras
qui sert de guichet pour passer de la
marchandise des équipements désormais
accessibles à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de belfort ici ont été
centralisés tous les matériels de la
protection possible gel visière blues
panneaux de signalisation tous fabriqués
par des entreprises locales
l'idée de base c'est d'abord avoir des
produits français et locales de
réinjecter dans notre territoire un
système économique important puisque les
entreprises qui ont entraîné
j ai qui ont créé jusqu'à 130 emplois
dans notre cas les peurs à un moment
très compliqué économiquement
visiblement ça marche en deux jours plus
de deux mille masques et 40 litres de
gel hydroalcoolique ont déjà été vendus